what i want to do in this video is get a
little bit of practice subtracting in
scientific notation
so let's say that i have
4.1
times 10 to the negative 2 power
4.1 times 10 to the negative 2 power and
from that i want to subtract
i want to subtract 2.6
2.6
times 10 to the negative 3 power and
like always i encourage you to pause
this video and see if you can solve this
on your own and then we can work through
it together
all right i'm assuming you've had a go
at it so the easiest thing that i can
think of doing is try to convert one of
these numbers so that it has the same
it's being multiplied by the same power
of 10 as the other one
and what i could think about doing well
what can we express 4.1
times 10 to the negative 2 can we
express it as something times 10 to the
negative 3.
so we have 4.1
times 10 to the negative 2.
well if we want 10 to the negative 2 to
go to 10 to the negative 3 we would
divide by 10. we can't just divide by 10
that would literally change the value of
the number in order to not change it we
want to multiply by 10 as well
so we're multiplying by 10 and dividing
by 10. i could have written it like this
i could have written
over 10
times let me write this a little bit
neater i could have written 10
over 10
times this and then you take 10 times
4.1 you get 41 and then 10 to the
negative 2 divided by 10 is going to be
10 to the negative 3. so this right over
here this is equal to 10 times 4.1 is 41
times 10
to the negative 3. and that makes sense
41 000
is the same thing as 4.1 hundredths and
all we did is we multiplied this times
10 and we divided this times 10. so
let's rewrite this we can rewrite it now
as
41 times 10 to the negative 3
minus minus
2.6
minus 2.6 times 10 to the negative 3.
so now we have two things we have 41 10
to the negative 3s minus 2.6 10 to the
negative 3s well this is going to be the
same thing as
minus 2.6
minus
2.6 let me do that same color
that was purple
minus 2.6 10 to the negative 3s
whoops 10 to the negative 3. there's 10
to negative 3 there 10 to the negative 3
there one way you think about it i have
just factored out a 10 to the negative
3.
now what's 41 minus 2.6
well 41 minus 2 is 39
and then minus 0.6 is going to be 38.4
38.4
and then you're gonna have times 10 to
the negative third third power
times 10 to the negative third power
now we this is what the product or this
is what the difference of these two
numbers is but this is no longer in
scientific notation in order to be
scientific notation
this number right over here has to be
has to be between 1 has to be greater
than or equal to 1 and less than
and less than 10.
so what we could do is we could divide
this number right over here by 10. we
can divide this by 10 and then we could
multiply and we could multipl so we
could do this
we could
kind of the the opposite of what we did
up here we could divide this by 10 and
then multiply by 10. so if you divide by
10 and multiply by 10 you're not
changing the value so 38.4 divided by 10
is 3.84
and then all of this business 10 to the
negative 3
10 to the negative 3 times 10 is 10 to
the negative 2 power so this is going to
be 3.84
times 10 to the negative 2 power